yo this is Rory I'm on the bootleg cab
show long overdue please stream my album
I'm begging you or find a streaming form
I thought it'd be different out tonight
if you know someone that is a streaming
Farm like I'd really really appreciate
it but it's bootleg Kev episode is great
we've been meaning to do this [__] mad
salacious Clips we talk about everybody
cat podcast special guest the homie Rory
is yes off the shroom gummies too off
the shrooms I took all seven which I
think says 12 but you know yes you're
about to have yourself a [__] trip
buddy I can't wait let's get let's get
some headlines yo uh well we're both
weren't on the list oh sorry I was gonna
say thank you I wanted to thank you
because you you and uh Mall show me some
love I know there was that uh complex
list that I don't know how you guys
didn't make it I have some ideas but
it's fun
but like I don't really like look into
that [__] too much you know I I honestly
like never expect to make that kind of
[__] so like when I saw you guys shot me
out it meant a lot it was cool man lists
aren't important in the scope of things
but they're great to talk about I love a
list I'm never above arguing about a
list or just talking about [__] the
weather we're on or not but I felt you
definitely should have been on it for
hip-hop media and you guys should have
definitely been on it I mean can we even
have the conversation of what what is
hip-hop media now to me you do hip-hop
media I'm not even quite sure if Maul
and I do hip-hop media I'm not sure if
the podcast space
is very much hip-hop media per se I
think you guys do comments touches
there's touches of it at this point
right but podcasting has had to expand
so much it's tough to like just do the
Hip Hop that's become Niche how crazy is
that biggest genre in the world the
podcasting has gotten so big you can't
just do yeah hip-hop [__] I think that's
why your guys are [__] is so dope could
you guys talk about just everything like
whatever's going on like you guys have a
take on it for the most part you know
yeah and uh it's good
how's everything uh with this album man
yeah you had sent me well you just sent
me the album like 20 before you showed
up sorry yeah all the way in I swore I
sent it to you before and then wait here
A bunch of songs before yeah
um that that are on the album obviously
but I haven't listened to it front to
back but I know this has been like your
baby for a long time yeah it's been a
long time coming to me when I started it
was maybe like three years ago and
luckily I had a lot of great excuses for
why it was taking so long right one was
the pandemic obviously and especially
for great excuse I loved it can't can't
do anything right
um also even like with the other pod
breakup like I had to reset on a lot of
stuff so even getting Mull and I show up
and running and you know starting from
zero with a whole new show was a task in
itself where the album kind of took a
bit of a back seat so you know it was
three years but I'm I can't say I worked
on it for three years like I had to stop
for a while which was good though
because I mean there's records had I put
this album out
two and a half years ago right I
probably would have [__] hated it and
I think I would have regret it so like
shout out to China for kovid and shout
out to the old show for breaking up like
shout out to the China virus yeah it
really I'm sorry for everyone that lost
grandparents but it really helped with
my album I lost my grandma Yeah also I
got more money than I ever had in the
pandemic so you know I can tell by the
plaques well these plaques are just
[__] these are [__] you know that
they send people who play songs that
didn't do it none of these [__] songs
you know broke my heart when I went into
certain producers Studios and saw all
the plaques but then realized they were
also DJs right and the labels used to
just send out plaques like you worked on
the miseducation of Lauren Hill and like
no no yeah like I got a lot of my OG
homies who have like a big L uh
a big picture plaque from Maracas yeah
and then like I started to realize like
damn everybody who's an old head in the
music industry I know has one of these
like not everybody could have worked on
this [__] like
and what did you work on on the big
picture like if you live in L.A
like what happened like you know but you
know one production credit that I see
here yeah so like the DJ plaques thing
is very like uh you know whatever I mean
I'm not gonna [__] turn them away
they look nice of course I'm jealous I
have no plaques I feel like I should
have some but I just never like went to
collect none of the emotional orange
stuff has gone gold yet yeah we're like
quadruple platinum in Korea so you got
to get one of them yeah I have to get a
Korean plaque for sure yeah well listen
for people who don't know uh because I
feel like a lot of people know you yeah
um but they might not necessarily know
your story
um kind of give me a breakdown on like
how you got even in because I I think I
first met you at like a Henny palooza in
La like maybe four or five years ago six
years ago was downtown
um but give me a breakdown on just kind
of how you got into the industry
obviously we know about the Joe Budden
podcast yeah
um well I mean it started well before
that yeah so um my barber in college by
Barbara I mean the only guy that had
Clippers on the floor from the dorm uh
shots my man Owen uh who I'm still
really cool with he was interning at Def
Jam and I didn't even know that was like
a thing right I was like you can you can
do that because there was like
internship programs at our college but
again I was like a freshman so I didn't
know much about that but I assume like
internship was like you interned at the
[__] financial aid office like I
didn't know there was real internships
per se
um he was like yeah I'll link you with
the person I'm interning for because I
guess like legally you could only do one
semester right Def Jam at the time right
so I interviewed with Shireen Taylor who
uh was at RCA forever she's been in
business forever too
um with her she was the assistant to
Gabby peluso ended up getting the
internship and kind of just going crazy
in that building like I I was
almost teetering on the line of annoying
but like I was right on that consistent
line where people [__] with me but I
was in every single Department talking
to every single person
um ended up linking with shot money and
just are even with the neighborhood
connection at that time he took me under
his wing and then where Shaw went I went
so I would say Gabby peluso Serene and
and Sean money were like the three
people that really introduced me into
the music business that's actually how I
met better Ben was working with sha
money Benner's now my manager and this
was when I was 19 I'm 33 now so did you
meet Benner at one of those random beat
conventions in Phoenix
yes that Shaw used to do um what were
the producer conferences what were those
called [__] I don't know I never could
go because at the time I was doing radio
in like Middle America but yeah I would
always see my friends I'd be like God
damn this is it was the producer
conference and shout out to Sean because
ahead of his time he had every producer
you could think of all within like a
Convention Center and they would have
Beats battles they would have like
conferences for producers they would
have like Tech [__] like shot is such an
adult thing with that you were at those
no I was in high school
um how I actually met better my manager
and this you know the podcast knows him
as well now was better and shot money
we're doing this thing called Def Jam
Cipher sessions Shaw was VP of a r at
Def Jam Better was moving around the
industry and they started this thing
that was like the main act at Def Jam at
the time for their region so for example
the first one was with Big Sean and then
a bunch of opening acts and then an
actual Cipher at sobs then they did the
South one that had big crit Cy then the
LA one the lineup was [__] nuts I
think it was
was it Kendrick Dom Jesus was nipsy on
that too
YG and this was 2000 2010 Jesus
yeah two different booty days 2010 2011
yeah
um so they just did different regions
and we did them all at sobs
um I mean I've talked to Big Sean later
in life and he was like yo that Def Jam
Cipher session [__] was like kind of the
thing that made the building pay
attention to me I wasn't just the what
you doing [__] and right kid at that
time like they were like hey maybe we
should give them Marvin Gaye and
Chardonnay right
um so it was really cool to be on the
ground floor with that stuff and by the
way what happened to Roscoe Dash anyway
continue hey
he could be on an undercard for verses
and do all right he I mean Super
undercard
yeah just like you know when people are
walking in it'd be like the Soulja Boy
Bow Wow undercard no you have to put
more respect on Roscoe Dash's name he
has some hooks that he could go crazy on
great yeah he's got no hands Marvin Gaye
and Chardonnay
all the way turned up yeah you have
Roscoe Dash [__] up is he got has he
got a fourth or fifth he might have some
writing credits that he could play as
well no he lives in Arizona by the way I
heard this has just been the Arizona
podcast already yeah
he was on oh my come on shout out
anyway we got sidetracked with Roscoe
Dash um uh but yeah from there uh I met
uh Aristotle who was a very talented
music video director who now is doing
feature films he just went to Sundance
uh wow he has a movie called story of
executive produced by Jamie Foxx but had
a company called by any means it was
actually J Cole's first manager
um and we ended up connecting with Kevin
Lyles at kwl and kind of just forming
like we were their creative team more or
less when they had Sean Trey that's when
300 came in so you know early Migos at
that time early Young Thug at that time
and we were just all on Park Ave with
[__] Kev lior and Todd just like
doing the create what the [__] are we
doing here type [__] leor sat across
from me in a desk that's like this wow
like not in a cubicle that's [__]
fire and he would just ask me the most
intimidating questions all the time with
no context why should I know you I don't
know I was like I feel like he could say
anything would be intimidating he's an
intimidating guy for sure really really
nice guy though but he's intimidating as
[__] I'm real tight with his uh brother
Marty but um I've never met lior but I
just watch all his interviews and I'm
like this dude I heard he's really tall
yes and he just seems like he's just he
speaks like a Russian hitman yeah and he
just leaves with like every every
question is uh to start to meet somebody
with why do I need to know you and
you're like a 19 20 year old kid like I
you know what you don't need to I'm
gonna just go home okay you guys you
don't need to know me bro you're rich
like I don't know I mean but no that but
that speaks to kind of why I think lior
amongst a million other things has been
so successful in his business I was just
some random kid that was doing [__] and
he was like yo what that wasn't uh try
to [__] on me question that was to try
to get to know me here's your
opportunity to tell me what you guys can
do and no I didn't say I just want to go
home I showed him uh stuff we were doing
for
the smaller Artisan 300 of like social
clips and like right we built was this
the Mike's dead era of 300 no it was uh
this kid from God he's from Washington
not DC like state
I forgot his name but we were doing a
lot of stuff yes this guy named
Macklemore Travis Thompson um shout out
to Travis
so yeah it was that's like was the early
stuff before like palooza and the Pod
hit and everything I'm sorry if I bore
people no I never think people want to
know that you have like a real real I
feel like not a lot like maybe people
were just you know a lot of people see
your guys as clips and they don't really
necessarily dive all the way in because
you guys have like two or three hour
long episodes yeah
um so you have like real roots in the
music industry but in both sides too
like I did the label [__] I did the
creative [__] I did the independent [__]
like I've I've kind of had every single
aspect of the music industry which I I'm
happy about and then you guys obviously
created a dope brand uh Henny palooza
which toured I mean for forever
yeah look yeah do say blue is it it's do
say palooza now or is it is it still a
thing it's not a thing no okay it's done
I don't know if I'm officially allowed
to say that but we're not we're not
coming back it's over yeah sorry if I we
didn't have like more of a
a whole closing type thing but yeah we
ended at the Barclays
um seriously Jokes Aside was a huge part
of that and then also after Kobe like we
all got kind of old like that [__]
becomes exhausting when you're traveling
around the world drinking yeah like a
lot yeah um yeah it becomes really
really tiring so I mean it was an ERA it
was an incredible thing I think it's in
the lineage of
parties within the culture like I think
it's up there in no way am I like saying
we're the tunnel but for our era like
that's a staple for our era as far as
what was going on in hip-hop at the time
with parties and I think we changed how
parties are now like the day party is
the thing now the Branded party is the
thing the club the clubs are you know
have been dying I think they're trying
to make a comeback with these these new
set of kids yeah I just opened a club in
Scottsdale and it's like a it's been
[__] great it's been amazing but you
know we've been lucky we kind of feel
there was no hip-hop clubs left in AZ so
we opened the spot and opened it right
before Super Bowl whatever happened to
that Rapper Juice from he goes by Richie
Evans now he was really dope still is
dope Richie's dope he's um
OG mugs my boy OG mugs manages him who's
like Tech Nine security and E-40
security and uh he just he just
performed a garyvee's v-con
okay
a little different than Black Wall
Street but yeah he goes by Richie Evans
now he was dope I always like juice a
lot juice was dope yeah the black wasp
and then we had hot rod
who was signed a G-Unit and then we had
Willie northpole who was signed a
ludicrous I remember Willie North Pole
and of course I remember hot rod hot rod
had a record with Mary J he did it's
called be easy and you know everything
about Hot Rod is he still lives in
Arizona he's kind of like a social media
like he runs some funny pages and stuff
shout out to him I think it shits Good
Times Jackson on Instagram but he was
really from Sacramento so Arizona really
never uh embraced him like that because
he was he was from Sacramento okay well
he I mean we all thought he was rep
Daisy that was a weird time in in G-Unit
super weird that was like when you could
you could tell it was like
you know I remember when I was super
excited that MLP and MOB deep were on
G-Unit
s blood money was a decent album there
were some singles on there
um
uh MLP never dropped an album on G-Unit
did they not that I remember no but I I
thought even in my young naive time at
that when they signed mob deep I love
Mobb Deep and I didn't think it was over
for Mob deep I just thought it was weird
that G-Unit was signing acts older than
them and I was like this is odd the MLP
signing I love MLP Warriors is one of my
favorite albums I [__] love MLP
I just I was like this is cool like
shout out to I as a kid I wasn't
thinking to myself like why is 50
signing guys that are older than him and
underground is fun yeah I was just like
this is lit like I didn't think anybody
was liked MLP but me you know what I'm
saying like I just figured it was all
some petty [__] behind the scenes
because wasn't MLP on Rockefeller yeah
then I think yes and then there was
something there was some other G Unit
Petty beef that he also signed that
makes a lot of sense [__] you hoe I'm
signing an MLP by the way the You Don't
Know Remix the only version of the song
I prefer yeah I agree blueprint too you
know what I mean I'm glad this is the
only podcast I can have juice
conversations on this is why so I didn't
come with my regular press run [__] I
just want to talk about juice from
Arizona Richie Evans
um yeah so you obviously um did you ever
have any sort of like
idea that you would even because you're
pretty like um you know I wouldn't say
you're like a an outward personality you
know what I mean like you're you're
pretty like chill dude like did you have
ever any sort of aspirations to be a
personality or I mean obviously you fell
into the podcast situation
um no but by any means absolutely not
like even with Palooza
everyone knows palooza you never saw me
unless you saw me losing my mind
backstage running around working like I
never wanted to be on stage even when
they would do like the moments of the
toast and all that [__] I never I don't
know maybe it's I don't know if it's
shyness I don't know it's only child
thing I'm just not I don't like
attention it makes me feel really really
uncomfortable and not in like the cool
way people say it like it makes me
really uncomfortable
um so I didn't but podcasting is is
drastically different in that regard
like
when we started the podcast I was you
know producing it for the first
beginning of it before I got on episode
seven whatever the [__] it was
um but that was very much a comfortable
thing because it was amongst friends it
was something we could control like and
it's you like
palooza with the hosts on stage and [__]
like you have to be the bravado the
charismatic like that that's something
that I don't possess so that would come
across very inauthentic and corny and I
would like nuts very cringy yeah yes I
don't think you want me to be like yo yo
put your [__] hands up I love I
love swag surf but I should not be
leading it that's all I'm saying yeah
um put your arm around the [__]
we're about to do the swag Surf and even
like the right I'm Rory
let's get my new drop actually
um and even with radio like
there is common radio personalities but
there is very much the flex or star or
even Ebro has a lot of especially New
York yeah but that's that's a little
Tamer like you know Envy's been very
successful as a radio personality
Rosenberg too and they're not like
really loud people in that regard
but podcasting was even more in my
corner I could just be myself the entire
time I don't have to turn something on
like all right we're back from a
commercial break and it's like that was
number 10 like I I would it would just
feel corny to me and I think it would
come across that way so it was never
something I wanted to do
um but podcasting for sure and that's
opened me up pause to other things that
I probably wouldn't have done like even
with the live shows I've shot my own
live show for the rollout of this album
like I got more comfortable in that
space knowing that I can do it myself
and do it the way I want to do rather
than the structure of what a radio would
be or what a party host would be or you
know a TV host right I can do the [__]
the way I want to and that's why I love
podcasting and you're not uh you're
obviously not screaming all over your
album no I [__] wish
thought about another
I thought about it I actually had um
I had a good amount of skits that were
pod related throughout the album like in
the early phases of it but then it
started to feel too much uh not parody I
would wouldn't use that word
but it felt too much like the Pod [__]
like this wasn't as serious as what the
album became you kind of wanted people
to like I mean yeah I mean I respect it
like you want people to take take the
music very serious and I'd be like is
what is this this is the podcast guy and
it was fun with someone like the Pod
skits I had in between and maybe I will
do that one day after I hope people take
me seriously on this one but yeah it
felt like I was I was doing a joke do
you uh because obviously there has been
like
you know compilation albums have been a
thing in hip-hop sure but uh even more
recently someone like Khaled who's
[__] huge and the Metro but Metro
Boomin produces but that's one of my
favorite albums decent memory
um there hasn't really been somebody I
mean I could be wrong but there really
hasn't been somebody in my
peripherals that has done the r b route
no I I mean I you can think of like a
Robert Glasper who's producing
everything and putting like black radio
3 was one of my favorite albums last
year
um so there's always been those type of
like producer albums per se and you're
like murder rating yeah and I mean no
still very much have a hand in the
production arranging and writing of
everything not to the degree of course
that Robert Glasper does but yeah very
much a part of each record uh yeah I
think r b needed that because this it
started out more as like an original
playlist is what I was going to call it
like let me get original records from
artists and put together my own playlist
of original music
um and then that turned into like hey
this feels more like an album and I've
never seen anyone in r b do this and
even with like the Khalid perspective
he gets the biggest names which is great
but there is especially now such a sub
genre where Superstars aren't as
important anymore for sure and fans have
these huge cult fan bases like you know
when you go on streaming and it says an
artist page you may like under here yeah
that's almost this version in an album
because there's so many like artists
that people have not heard of but
they've heard of another artist and this
fan base is just waiting to hear from
this artist so let's put them together
and then you do get moments where I'll
get a j Electronica and put him on a
song with Reggie who is brand new that
would never happen on a Khalid project
it would just be Jay Electronica and
[__] Jay-Z yeah it's like let me do
some stuff that wouldn't happen
otherwise unless I do it and I'm a huge
Griselda fan I'm always on the album
always wanted to hear Conway on
something that would be more played at h
m
more of a dance record uh you know
something you can try on tight t-shirts
too and Conway doesn't sound weird on it
at all no yeah that's one of the records
you sent me this [__] shout out to uh
Conway who I feel like Conway can really
do anything oh he
I don't think I told this story
I don't know
um when I sent it to Conway I met up
with him at engine room in uh in the
city he was like why did you send me
that record and I was like oh [__] what
the [__] did I do because you know just
like Leo he's an intimidating guy just
for different reasons right
um probably had a cigarette or a bag
yeah and a whole bottle of Hennessy yes
um and he was like why'd you send me
that that type of record I was like I
mean I just wanted to hear you on
something like that and he was like no
thank you everyone just sends me beats
that sound like Alchemist sir and he was
like I would have done the verse for you
because like I [__] with you but when
you sent that like I got excited to come
cut this first finally someone sent me
something that wasn't in the same realm
whenever they want a [__] Griselda
feature so that like those types of
sessions were like real wins to me
behind the scenes like I was able to get
artists to do [__] that they wanted to
do but maybe didn't have the opportunity
to do as far as sound a lot of times
these guys get typecasted with the type
of Beats they they get sent you know
what I mean it's like
you know I've heard I heard a there was
a I don't know if Conway ever played you
the song he had that's never going to
come out but we've talked about it on
the podcast but he had a record with hit
maker
that was on him make a beat that sampled
I think it sampled some Biggie or
something yeah a boogies on it sorry I
choked on my own my record's [__]
crazy super crazy radio single yeah I
think uh I'm not
gonna speak on the politics of what
stopped that but uh that record was
crazy it was it was a biggie sample yeah
Boogie
um I think someone else on it maybe
Jeremiah maybe yes could be I have it in
my phone from a long time ago but
there's a lot of those those beats that
I feel like risotto wanted to do and had
to wait
but I think they took their time in the
right way I think what Benny's doing I
think you know Conway with the Justice
League thing that's about to come out
right as well is perfect and yeah I
think they've they've changed their
their sound I uh just watched the
entirety of your guys's
blog era Jeopardy or whatever the [__]
it was I watched the whole thing shout
out to it's the real Jeff Eric yeah
because they have the new the new uh
podcast which is phenomenal by the way
yeah the first episode was great
um because I was like wow the blog ERA
this is my life yeah
um but that [__] was that [__] was that
was great man that was a [__] yeah it
was it was you you won too I think you
smoked everybody that's my era yeah
that's definitely my era and I mean
anywhere home home turf SOB stage like
it's where I was birthed
oh it was at sobs yeah we did people if
you know you know type of thing that was
more this will be once like once it was
such a staple for New York City and the
blog era it was like we could shoot this
at my crib we could shoot this at some
stage but doing it at sobs made it feel
cooler even if no one realized we were
at sobs who to you is like the biggest
blog era
Woulda Coulda what if Charles Hamilton
by far oh my God me too no it's not even
close and I mean that and I mean that
respectfully I don't mean that in like I
remember there was that YouTube video of
Charles Hamilton backstage I think the
game was in it was Kanye there yes
Charles Hamilton is a snapping he was uh
the Green Lantern mixtape with uh where
he sampled stained outside I'm only yeah
wait am I am I confusing that with
[__]
that's Charles Hamilton right I'm sure
he's sampled stain before
I can almost guarantee it I'm confusing
that or a mood music but I mean the uh
Joe also sampled that um pink lava lamp
was one of my favorite
from the blog era as far as mixtapes and
if you look at Charles Hamilton
outside of just his sheer Talent he had
Jimmy Iovine and Jimmy Iovine banked on
him too that's a different type of
animal when you have Jimmy ivine that's
why he's in rooms with game and Kanye
that early
was it the pink backpack yeah it's just
listen man mental health and and prayers
to him I know he still does make music
but I've always been a Charles Hamilton
fan I don't mean that in a way like dude
me too [__] I know he went through a lot
before him a lot I mean he was and he
was even
I think two years ahead of even where
music was about to go with the blog era
as far as
I don't like the word nerd but switching
over to that being like an actual nerdy
guy yeah yeah like yeah he referred to
himself as a blogger before like for
sure I remember uh there was a song that
he sampled
um
was it he sampled uh like the sounds of
like Windows and like I forget what it
was but he he also had that high output
that got to the point where I was just
like I don't know what's going on
anymore yeah I don't know how many
z-share [__] links this guy's [__]
dropping he had like [__] 30 mixtapes
and then he ended up beefing with Royce
over the uh the Dilla thing yeah which
was a mistake but that's being it felt
like that was the beginning of being the
quote-unquote nerd and not realizing
even if you are from Harlem Cleveland
whatever like
not knowing that you're just a J dilla
fan
but not realizing how offensive that
could be to the family that you just
said your album was executive produced
by him and he passed you didn't even
doubt like you didn't even steal some
Dilla beats on the internet like you
just said you saw him in a dream and he
executive produced it and it's like that
can get really offensive to people that
were friends with him and now he's dead
like yeah he tried to make it and
Detroit is just not one of those cities
when he tried to make a comeback a few
years ago was it three or four years ago
yeah I was like oh
yeah he did um he did an interview on
HOT97 I think he had a record out with
Rita Ora was like The Comeback I think
so I could I could be wrong but I think
Rita Ora
and
he looked healthy but you could tell he
was like really really on meds like Med
said meld him out like a little too much
right and I think he just wasn't ready
for a comeback because it didn't look
like there was creativity it just looked
like he was netted the [__] out didn't
make it onto your album
I would definitely work with Charles
Hamilton depending on where his health
was as far as like a human being he's
not alien bro he's amazing and all the
the stunts that he did at that time
we would deem genius had there been a
different result and I think a lot of
the results had to do with his mental
health and the situations he was in but
all that [__] we're talking about with
the 30 albums all the internet [__] he
was doing only putting music out on his
website
um even the stunts he was doing with the
Lady Gaga [__] the Rihanna [__] even
down to the J dilla thing to some degree
if that would have turned out better and
he wasn't who he was as a person we
would be like Charles Hammond is a
genius he mastered the internet first
yes exactly yeah and it's ahead of his
time and that's what's so crazy about
the internet and artists like it just
takes like one or two things that can
change your entire Legacy from looking
like a genius to looking like an
absolute I would say that [__] about
riff raff I'm like guys riffraff was so
ahead of the cloud era like he was like
the original like SoundCloud clout
rapper he was just doing what this
[__] had a world star tattoo a
bet tattoo what is he like what does he
do now he still raps he's just joked
like he looks like a [__] bro he
looks like a gnarly wrestler bro like
he's got a mo solid and [__] Shades
and
I don't know man I'd never really paid
attention to riffraff like that I always
just loved his YouTube videos where he
would just rant like ramble because he
would just say like he's genuinely like
a [__] funny guy yeah but I never
like you know dived into Riff Raff's
music
I did DJ for him once at Ultra in Miami
please let me know how that went it was
good like how'd you guys put the setlist
together can you tell me the Green Room
like so I got hit up what was on the
rider I don't know about that how many
times did he use the best I was living
in Tampa at the time and at the time
riff Ras got a [__] uh Iced Out shark
Grill naturally yeah of course right
right right so they needed a DJ my boy
Mike Lieberman was working with him so I
ended up DJ in for him at Ultra and
acted like he's performing a bunch of
girls he's got like all these cutouts of
himself and his uh husky he's got a
husky that's famous okay uh uh and then
like on the Fly he decides he wants to
DJ an EDM set like on my computer with
my library yeah so you had everything
set up no I didn't I know I'm sure
you know I'm trying to like talk him
through like you know there's like intro
mix show intro versions of songs and I'm
like on the Fly trying to like help him
hip-hop DJ trying to teach someone who's
never DJ'd how to do an EDM set in the
middle of on during his set at home at
Ultra and it was perfect it was a
[__] mess good guy though good guy
you guys still stay in contact
we haven't talked for a while he's a
nice guy though I like I like her if he
lived in Chandler Arizona for a while
him is Huskies everything does go back
to Arizona I guess they do what do you
want from me man go Sons
um but yeah no shout out to riffray you
know who else was a big what if for me
was XV oh love XV yeah wow Wichita album
yeah XV was dope executive produced by
just blaze zero Heroes
what did happen XV uh I still follow him
he just put out some music but he had
that out he had zero Heroes which was so
fire you Priya pre-blog era and I was
talking to Jeff and Eric about this I
don't think it ever made you know on
camera though there was a time when I
thought Drake and Nicholas F were a
group
because at a time like yeah
even before blogs per se it was just
like there would just be websites where
they would just post a bunch of [__]
music there was like 35 Drake and
Nicholas F [__] and then comeback season
came out and I was like oh did they
split up yeah what happened to that guy
too by the way uh Nicholas been around I
actually think he was doing something in
media I remember there was a random
fonte Drake record was Nicholas f on it
with him no you're talking about uh
think good thoughts that was not a
random record relax it's an incredible
record it was like a it was like a Lucy
no it was on comeback season ninth of
the beat oh elzai I think was supposed
to there's an elzy verse that didn't
make it I believe and I'm really nerding
out now comeback season think of
thoughts fonte Drake you have fonte on
this album I do yes which is like
amazing it's bigger than having to hold
on it to me I [__] love little
brother my favorite artist and it's not
even close
fonte is a special guy uh it's crazy how
historically slept on he is how talented
he is he's amazing singer too you got a
singer singing or rapping singing yeah
cause he could sing he's what was the uh
projects He was putting out for foreign
exchange foreign exchange this is very
much the producer's name uh Nicolette
yeah Nicholas very talented um yeah
other side of my album is definitely
fonte and shout out to be my Fiasco
who's um signify extremely talented
singer from North Carolina it's very
much in the early foreign exchange house
bag
which was some of my favorite stuff like
you know I was a rap nerd fan but little
brother as far as like even the samples
ninth would pick or fonte getting into
the foreign exchange bag kind of
not of course introduce me to r b but as
a young kid that was such a hip-hop nerd
it made me
pay attention to it and start to do the
Deep Dives I had done with the hip-hop
[__]
yeah so fonte being on this r b project
is like such a full circle moment
because so much of what he was putting
out when I was 12 years old was on this
album like what I started to appreciate
within r b came from that type of stuff
do you like Minstrel show or the
listening more uh missile show I don't
know if I'm allowed I don't know if
either of us are allowed to say that I
like this well I mean yeah because the
name of the album but I [__] love him
um listening of course is incredible and
a classic but
as much as I am their underground rap
nerd fan I am very much
just equally as big a fan of
hip-hop that people would say isn't
really hip-hop like popular hip-hop
right I'm really into that type of stuff
and the minstrel show to me was the
perfect balance for little brother where
they had to try some [__] where their
their core fan base may not like but
someone like me loves that [__] like go
go to Atlantic go try to get a hit
record because I like hit records I'm
not that nerdy fans like don't sell out
like not sell out a little bit it could
work a hit a hits a hit for a reason
it's you know and I mean of course they
did but they ran into politics um with
loving it but yeah to me musically like
menstrual show is is perfect the
listening is very much
in that college dorm which and you kind
of look like Joe Scott a little so
you're probably like yo Joe's gotta yes
well I could make it too
who is a friend and everything walks
around with me and we've got a
restaurant in Atlanta right he does yeah
shout out to Joe Scott and every time I
go to his restaurant in Atlanta the
staff always asks me if I'm related to
him every single time
Joe's cousin no
just a fan
that's big to have fonte on the project
uh you got drums on there yes uh Ari
Lennox who else is on this James sponsor
is on the project and I mean can I brag
of course
maybe I'm the only one that finds that
[__] insane I don't even know who
that is you don't know what James
Foxworth is uh he's probably one of the
greatest writers of all time are you
familiar with cocaine 80s yeah of course
yeah he's the singer of cocaine oh [__]
see yeah uh do you like the 2020
experience by Justin Timberlake and 80s
was the [__] that uh no idea no idea
produced I just was with no ID last
night that's crazy let him know we want
another cocaine 80s project
um
but uh yeah he also wrote all the 2020
experience for Justin Timberlake he's
working for my favorite Justin
Timberlake album yeah he's he's a legend
to me and cocaine 80s is by far one of
my favorite groups even though there is
only four mixtapes I remember yeah those
tapes were crazy and I was even looking
up old tweets when we put that record
out and it was kind of like a really
cool full circle moment and made me like
feel a little Standish about the amount
of times like I was tweeting James
sponsor Roy in 2010 but yo it's crazy
how long ago that is bro if you think
about like
I was just talking to my boy because I
was we were talking about high school
and I was like bro high school was 20
years ago 20. like
bash it's crazy that [__] feels like it
was like six years ago like it's just
terrifying to look at what I thought
for sure you know I've had to delete so
much [__] on my Twitter and not even on
like the cancellation that's not what
I'm talking about pauses and no homos I
had to take off my Twitter timeline
that's one thing yeah
that's just a whole separate issue just
looking at like just dumb [__] like you
really like you really thought you were
smart at that age for sure I was really
talking very confidently on Twitter at
21 years old like I really had the world
figured out for sure and I was like
judging other people and the fashion
[__] was great even like when you guys
did that blogger thing in the old boy
dressed uh he had the Good Wood [__]
yeah I was like damn that was that was a
wave The Good Wood and the [__]
loud ass ten deep and I had a 10 Deep a
long sleeve shirt on that man all that
[__] was a diamond supply this they had
a snapback [__] it was [__] crazy
Karma Loop era Karma loop I remember you
going that Karma Loop but you just see
what I would just get whatever's on sale
yeah they had like all the little
independent Brands and [__] I got so
many random just hip-hop teas like
Rocksmith and all that [__] like that
was that was a fun error too and I know
where we're been staying on the blog
here but I don't mind uh when I was with
Aristotle and by any means we had an
office before we went in with Kev at kwl
we were in the karma Loop office for a
year and a half maybe I'm talking about
like when the fat Jew was walking around
way like when he was a rapper and like
this kid like Joey Badass and his
friends who were like in high school
would just run a [__] muck like was
Karma Lou was that a Boston thing it
started out that way and then they went
on 27th Street in the city when they got
like a lot of investors and that's when
we were in there
um and like just thinking back
the office era is gone and I don't know
if this is bad content but
that Karma Loop office was a place for
like all Creative Kids Network the ASAP
kids were in there the new era kids were
in there running into people like fat
Jew and clearly we see where he is now
uh Pharrell would be in there like just
it was just a spot to hang out and even
pre-covered I just don't think that
happens or maybe I just got old and
there is like even a life was a store in
New York but that was a place kids hung
out like there's no stores everything's
gotten so [__] corporate if there's
just not a lot of kick in it anymore
like I was at an event I was at killer
Mike's album release party last night
and I was like this is the one of the
first times I've because I don't be
doing [__] bro like if anything like
Killer Mike or something like I really
[__] with or I ain't getting paid I'm
just not there like the last I saw and
say what you will about Adam 22 I'm not
here to have any of that conversation
but when I went to his like compound
that he has now when Maul and I did the
show with him and A.D I was like that
was the last time people were just
hanging out yeah I was like damn I
missed when people did this you've been
in the news spot yeah the new one and it
was just had young kids hanging out
older people hanging out creatives
hanging out like that's those spaces
don't exist anymore I was happy to see
that when I went to no jumpers you're
about to do uh the Fig Community world
today right yeah with uh well we have
gone 80 spot yeah that's that's the name
of the show fig Community world I think
right yeah but it won't be at the no
jumper no of course yeah obviously okay
I was like no [__] don't worry then Kev
no it's like I don't know if you missed
it there was a there was a big thing it
was huge thing yeah which I mean I feel
like I started that Trend but you know
just breaking away oh these breakups are
my sons I mean listen that's why when I
interviewed I had ad on the show him and
t-rail right after and I was like hey
man
I've known ad for a very long time yeah
I was like you got really thick skin
I was like you mean to tell me you
weren't planning this all along you you
took so much offense to someone saying
you had the same three jokes that you
said [__] you I'm out I don't know if I
don't know if you watched our episode of
the no jumper A.D breakup clip but I
said something very similar I'm like
all right I'm not saying 80 is not
allowed to feel offended but something
just isn't adding up you wanted to leave
bro yeah so like you got your out
yeah and I even went as far as to say
like all right if that's all that was
said in my last pod we'd still be
potting first for sure I was told not to
show up to your son's birth way
different than hey you make the same
joke for like bro what like you have
thick skin yeah I've said worse than
I've been making fun of 80s veneers for
five years since he got him like on the
radio in La like
yeah I mean there's definitely a
compilation clip we can make of me
talking about 80s teeth I was talking
about him with Hannibal Burris because
Hannibal burst put our song called
veneers and I was like have you seen
a.d's teeth what is I'm scared to click
Hannibal rapping I'm very scared to
click it I'm a huge Hannibal Buress I
love a comedy fan so even when he would
do his rap [__] on stage when he would
do his T-Pain show on stage hilarious he
did the Mumble rap thing I'm terrified
and this is crazy coming from me because
I'm a podcaster that is talking about
putting an album out on Friday so so I'm
not taking away from his talent yeah I'm
just scared to click it so he put a song
out called veneers that is like a more
of a comedic angle okay easing into it I
get it he played me some stuff that was
really good
um
I mean I was like yo you're like he I
guess he's been rapping before he was
doing comedy yeah and I know he's always
always been a real real hip-hop fan like
for real the stuff he played me was
really good he has another song that's
coming out called like I look like lift
weights that's like a joke song okay I
mean it's cool it's it's you know we'll
see I don't know he's gonna obviously
run into issues of people taking him
serious you know but he has to do like a
leaker's freestyle or like a sway yes
like he just to he has to show I
understand easing people in but he has
to go to Five Fingers of Death or
something exactly and like Shia labeoufa
would have dropped an album after he did
sway people would be like oh [__] let me
go check this Shia LaBeouf album no he
kind of went crazy he went crazy on that
[__] what happened after like he was
working another another Charles Hamilton
situation man super talented people that
unfortunately get in their own way of
things they probably can't control but
even like Hannibal I love that he's
doing that I hope he doesn't go full
like
Little Dicky with it where like every
song is going to be kind of a joke no he
played me some serious songs that were
dope like he was really rapping but he
he should be able to do that and I mean
kind of same thing with my project like
yeah we are creative in one area we can
also be creative in other places people
are gonna always want to put you in a
little box yeah and especially Hannibal
is a certified comedian like there's
it's solidified oh [__] he's fine I'm
sure he's doing fine financially as well
so why not go do some [__] that you like
ah like move on to the next thing still
do comedy but that's why I mean it's
pretty much what he was saying he was
like now if I get a book for a comedy
show like they know they have to know
like I'm gonna also do some of my music
yeah you know like I'm gonna do the
stand-up thing but I'm gonna do some
music and what's so funny I mean even
podcasting like most of the podcasters
that are doing [__] we're doing stuff
before we didn't go to school for radio
broadcasting like we're all doing other
[__] and we're like oh well we have good
opinions we know how to express
ourselves let's do this this seems like
a long-form version of that for you guys
like uh obviously
you guys had never planned to break away
and do your own thing it's gone really
really well despite not making lists
um and think about hanging it up but
it's gone really really well you guys
are doing a great job I feel like you
know I think like
I feel like you guys each have like such
a dope like nuanced perspective on a lot
of [__] that's like I just like if you
guys talk about music you know what I
mean
um don't feel like there's any hater
[__] going on like but for you guys like
how are you guys approaching on the
Creator side like the business of this
whole thing because I'm sure once you
get on the other side of the curtain and
you're like oh this is how much money is
out there yeah for yo what up it's
bootleg cab we gotta stop the interview
to tell you about our folks at my bookie
that's right so many ways you can gamble
with my bookie right now man of course
you got NBA playoffs Western Conference
Finals Eastern Conference Finals they're
set I love Celtics vs Lakers in the
finals all right you can sign up at
mybookie.ag right now using that promo
code bootleg and get a very generous
first deposit bonus that's right and
they just got the craziest like revamp
of the online casino it's like a Las
Vegas experience if you play cards
Blackjack roulette uh you shoot dice
whatever it is they have like live
dealers handling it for you wherever
you're at you could be at the airport
and be playing [__] roulette on your
phone it's amazing mybookie.ag sign up
with that promo code bootleg right now
you can bet on Sports you can do slots
you could do Blackjack uh craps whatever
you're into mybookie.ag promo code
bootleg for that first deposit bonus and
it is a generous one also gotta give a
shout out to our family at King Palms
shout out to King Palm man if you only
know about King Palms they are a new
sponsor on the bootleg kit podcast and
they got such a great product the best
thing about King Palms is it's all
organic man no tobacco in these wraps
they're straight Leafs and the best
thing uh about them is they got this
product
their flavor terpene tips all right you
stuff them with your with your product
do we got one here oh we do got one here
all right we have one right here we got
one right here all right you stuff this
with your uh premium cannabis from Hardy
in Las Vegas
all right you smoke up pinch that tip
you're gonna get a burst of flavor yeah
this is the energy drink flavor we got
Peach pineapple we got watermelon wave
also don't forget the goddamn
blue grapes you know what I mean and
also this is a tobacco-free wrap it's
totally organic it's literally a leaf
let me show you what I mean
that is just a big ass Leaf guys all
right so what you could do is go to
kingpom.com weeds flying everywhere
kingpop.com promo code bootleg and uh
you can get 50 off of whatever you order
at kingpom.com and don't forget to check
them out because they're everywhere your
local smoke shop your local liquor store
7-Eleven smoke the King Palm all right
it's organic it ain't like all that
other [__] y'all be [__] stuffing
in your lungs man all right shout out to
kingpong kingpom.com promo code bootleg
right now and it's actually promo code
bootleg Kev
half off everything let's get back to
the interview
we did it we did a great great deal with
Sirius and Stitcher that I can't say
enough good things about they've they've
been really good and it was a licensing
deal we were able to own our entire
catalog uh once the deal is up we can
leave with our catalog a lot of
Licensing deals they'll hold your
catalog for five to ten years like a
platform podcast so they're a big
podcast platform that Sirius ended up
purchasing serious exam yes so we're
Stitcher we have a deal with Stitcher
but serious own Stitcher so so what does
Stitcher get
so Stitcher gets our content and they're
able to license our just our audio
content not our video
um to advertisers that they have within
their Network so you so you guys are
able to monetize the audio aspect of the
podcast which is a big deal because for
you guys you're like cool [__] our
Brandon Butters YouTube yeah for sure so
we're gonna make this bag over here on
the audio side what are we doing and we
already know that the audio aspect
unless you're doing things like it's the
real with the blog era or right yeah uh
even like what Kenya Barris is doing
with like those you know voiceovers
like I listen to Bill Simmons a lot so
much of of where our genre is already
like I'm not saying anything that I'm
not saying some groundbreaking [__]
right now everything's moving
individuals so us holding on to our
visuals was
very much important but
like I was saying before of how I'd
pause the album to get this [__] up and
running
it requires some capital and if we can
give up our audio just on the licensing
side so we can get this [__] moving and
hire the right people and get the
studios and get equipment like that's
especially with the window we had like
if you guys had a window where it was
like everyone's looking at rorian mall
what are they going to do next yeah so
it's it's so I mean it's funny to hear
you know with the internet with the
check chasing thing which is is you know
people sound smart to people that are
dumb so I don't even really care to try
to correct them in that regard but to
check Chase in our situation is insane
yes we did take a check
for an audio licensing deal to get some
Capital up and running like [__] we
have our visual
um I I I'm not sure where
will be when this deal is done but I
have nothing bad to say about Sirius or
Stitcher I loved everything that we did
with them so I don't touch any of the
YouTube Revenue no oh wow so you're yeah
so yeah it was it was a great situation
for the time that we were in but to your
original question that also allowed us
to see the landscape now that we could
kind of relax for a second while getting
our staff together while we're getting
our space together like you know I know
we were on that pod for five six years
prior right
that does get erased
when you don't leave with anything from
it yeah you don't take you're not taking
anything I don't take a camera I don't
take the camera I don't take none of
like and on top of that with podcasting
people don't talk about the Synergy
amongst the camera guys the editors
right the day-to-day people the managers
like that's a big thing in itself too
yes Maul and I have chemistry because
we're on a pot for so long you could put
a mic in front of us and I'm confident
we can get great content but to take it
to the next level that requires building
a team that's that's why podcasting is
so valuable because there's so much
chemistry that's what people are
attracted to that happens behind the
camera for sure that chemistry is not
just on the microphone for sure so that
took some time as well and that takes
Capital too like yeah the type of people
that I want to work with aren't gonna
work off a dollar in a dream and they
shouldn't I wouldn't want to do that to
them so yeah I thought our our serious
deal was
perfect thing to take and it wasn't the
most amount of money like we have higher
offers for licensing deals that I did
not think worked best for the situation
that we were able to own more they
wanted more so in some cases there was
companies that wanted to own some but in
other cases there was people I just felt
wouldn't license our content in the best
way and I'm not going down to the ads
for say like pollution and [__] but just
how they would deal with wait a second
oh no no shout out to Bluetooth
Bluetooth
oh no our podcast is the blue Live Crew
you know what oh I love the Bluetooth
man yeah no we just we pop them even
when we don't have you know you just
[__] we're addicted to [__] wake
up in the morning with that Bluetooth
dick man uh but even with a higher money
I just some of those companies I didn't
feel like I wanted to be in business
with and neither did more
Sirius made the most sense with the
amount of Freedom we would get Capital
we would get the time the deal was and
what we had to turn over in the small
window we had so you know I I love the
narratives that have been put out there
I laugh at them too I'm a big I'm on
Reddit all the time as well like I see
everything and my other free only fans
content of course not well that's that's
not my algorithm right
um my lack of my lack of responding does
not make something true and I know me
saying that does not matter to the
internet but I don't care is there like
so the only Reddit thing I jumped into
was the no jumper Reddit oh that's
that's a that's spicy it's a nasty Place
well because I so I was hit up by Adam
to do the first show without a DNT rail
this was the the day that he fired Lush
on camera yeah he hits me up and he's
like hey man you're down to do the show
tomorrow and I was like yeah I've been
on the show before so I was like yeah
okay whatever no idea you know then I
see oh this will fire Lush on camera
today so I call A.D and I'm like hey man
uh what's going on over there he's like
bro I'm about to [__] quit
and I was like what the [__] I was like
what am I walking into he's like dude
just do it just do it you know I was
like all right so I do it and everyone's
assuming like I'm the replacement yeah
and I'm like dude I'm not the
replacement but they were eating me
alive on Reddit
it was hilarious of course I mean of
course they're gonna do that I'm shocked
they didn't pause Adam more on that
because in the Lush and A.D thing there
was also the white supremacist thing was
going on at that time yeah there was
like the joke about the slave owners
yeah there was a lot of [__] so like
throwing me or you is like the
replacement probably wasn't the best
move but and I feel
I feel feel for Adam not on that side
but I feel I feel for him as far as like
[__] just one day a whole operation is
moving and then you lose that and then
and then the next I have empathy for
Adam me too me too for sure I told him I
said dude you're [__] mentally
strong brother because during that time
there was everybody was like [__] no
jumper and then that dude rolled up
there on the live stream with that old
ass [__] that he'd already put the bed
and rehashed that and it was just like
but that's that's the tough [__] outside
of everything and stuff for the internet
to some degree when people have been
waiting for your downfall they're
waiting they will make small things into
the largest thing ever for sure and even
when things pass the next time a small
thing will happen that's why I did
everything I could not understand like
Joe grilling him so bad because I was
like dude
really I I thought it was appropriate I
just did I just was like
I just feel like if if people wanted to
like rehash old [__] like like you know
like if somebody wanted to be a dick
there's a lot of old Joe Budden [__]
that is like hearsay or for sure that
people could just stir up if they ever
wanted you know what I mean I I didn't
it was on whatever the radio yeah yeah
um no I did listen to it I thought uh I
didn't think
Joe was harsh on him I thought it was
appropriate if you're gonna have Adam on
your show at that time you gotta address
you and Joe would look even crazier if
you're trying to get the guy that all
the attention is on right now for clicks
and then you don't and then you don't
and then you feed your softballs you
look [__] nuts so I didn't think
there but also why I and I'm a hypocrite
a lot I try not to grill
people on a lot of stuff because to your
point like not to the degree of like
racism or something but we all have our
[__] so and we're all gonna have our
moments especially in this world I'm not
one of those
people in the media that protects each
other right I I'm in the middle there
there's some people that are like we're
all media we can't post bad things about
us because like we don't want to get to
War I think I think that's corny as [__]
for sure but also going super in on
someone for small mistakes if some
things are inexcusable for sure
I'm not big on just doing that and maybe
that's probably not good in the content
game for me to feel that way I I should
do that for Content purposes but I just
I have my own [__] too like
yeah I'm just not gonna [__] scream
at someone when they make a mistake I've
done it before don't get me wrong but at
this point in my life you feel like
you've grown
just in perspective perspective is
important
uh I just saw you I didn't know you had
a daughter until I saw the video you
just posted yes I mean I didn't even
send you the album by accident so I
didn't send the ultrasound no so uh how
old is your daughter
a little over three months well
congratulations thank you has that
changed your life drastically I mean
obviously besides like waking up but has
it like some people I mean listen I have
a son that's 18 I had him when I was
well he's about to be 18. I had him when
I was 18. so I had him when I was 18.
but that you know it was so long ago I
couldn't like I just was like trying not
to be poor and be homeless you know
understandable so like I don't know like
like what did that what does that do for
you like mentally
um it's weird I used to look at like
parents when they would say like
memeable
like corny basic [__] about kids I'm
like all right I'm sure it's like we get
it yeah I get it but I it makes me stop
it like reminds me of Joy just like just
looking at her makes me stop where I
never would have stopped like that's the
the surface level of how it's changed my
life it's like little moments
I lacked little moments in my life until
her of course she's the biggest moment
but but just watch a little moments
created little moments in my life that I
never had before and like makes me
re-observe
everything like I sound like the corny
parent now that I'm saying like I'm I'm
walking her in a stroller looking at her
and she's looking up at trees and I'm
like [__] this is amazing remember
trees remember those
and she is just amazed by [__] so I
don't know if it's selfish to say this
but it also has allowed me to like be
reintroduced to so much things within
these three months of watching her
observe other [__] that I've had around
me forever right like it makes me even
appreciate
[__] a bit more like just her curiosity
of everything makes me feel weird do you
feel like because I always say to myself
I'm like okay I go to New York City like
when I go to New York
I'm always like I like it I can never
[__] live here this is [__] insane
like I say the same thing about other
really yeah
so I go to New York and I'm like
everyone's rubbing on each other every I
mean I appreciate everyone's on the
[__] grind they're going to work
they're [__] just you know mission to
wherever they got to go but I'm always
like I could never like I'm I'm sure
raising a kid in New York you're raising
a strong [__] kid no matter what
because they got to deal with [__] that
nobody else in the US really has to deal
with in terms of just going to school
yeah for sure going to the grocery store
whatever would you public transportation
makes you a
man having a more Woman daughter are you
like we might need to get like out the
city a little bit I mean it's such a
different New York than the one I know
um like she would be raising a way way
different New York but yes it has
crossed my mind and my
entirely I was never going to leave New
York New Jersey Jersey was as far as you
know I just bought a crib in Jersey
that's as far as I was going to venture
off right
I it's changed within these three months
you're like huh maybe Atlanta's not so
bad and it was it was funny let me uh
name drop pardon if I if I drop the name
uh I was talking with our Branch when we
went down shout out to my guy out we
went down to Atlanta to shoot some stuff
I think for bet and we used his studio
um him and says the studio
and he was telling me he's like I've
seen Queens my whole life like I never
wanted to leave I was never going to
leave even when the music industry
started to leave New York I was holding
strong
he said my daughters no I had I had to
get out like the schools are better here
I love being able to just go pick them
up drive off like they're around fresh
air all the time like they can just
explore like it's just it's just a
different perspective and I feel them on
that I I think it could happen La no
because I think La is just the same as
New York just with
palm trees well there's the valley and
valleys the Valley's nice well I I was
always [__] on
La not La the city
La the transplant La not la oh yeah
transplant L.A so obnoxious but that's
where if I were to move to LA at that
time would I would have been around
transplant sure then I got to know a lot
of people that grew up in La grew up in
the valley and I saw a whole nother side
of it where I was like okay I understand
why people think this is the greatest
city in the world not a place that I
would move or bring my kid but
I have eased up on La I've explored
around and really got to know I was in
West Hollywood for like five years I
would just come land work if you're only
in West Hollywood you're like this is
like there's Billboards everywhere
there's my safe haven was Saddle Ranch
like that's all that's why trashy for
sure I mean look at me don't don't let
the my parents I'm like traffic my
parents are coming to LA and they're
like we gotta go somewhere I'm assuming
just assuming I'm stereotyping my own
parents they'd be like that sound ranch
place they got a bull in there
let's check that out you know I was with
jelly roll at Saddle Ranch like a year
ago like singing Carrie country karaoke
oh we brought the whole team there for
our last La show and
edin roll the bull Damaris rode the bull
everyone rode the bull yeah there's
other areas yeah you know and then
obviously downtown's a [__] wild
place that [__] uh reason brought me
around like it's Carson area yeah the
outro on the album right yes uh that we
produce with bank and um one of my
favorite producers Legend Coleman who
um did the intro on Kohl's 85 South oh
he did okay I think that's the right
name right 95 north 95 North shout out
to 85 South that's the one with camera
on it right yes 95 North great song um
Coleman produced Apple boy wonder he's
to me one of the
probably the most talented new producer
that I think everyone is going to really
gravitate to soon even when Bing started
on I sent it over to Coleman to help us
out with like keys and other stuff and
Bank was like yo can I sign him like who
this kid is incredible right
um so yeah Bank Coleman reason sobering
thoughts on the Mondrian it actually
came from a conversation reason I had
when he was dropping me off at the
Mondrian and we sat in the car and
talked for like an hour and a half great
guy and I was like oh one of the best I
was like this we had another song called
reasonable ending which I think might be
licked on YouTube at this point people
had heard it and I said we gotta redo
this like let's let's get a whole new
beat let's start this conversation we
just had needs to be the outro
um and Drake actually DM me and said
with a drake ass title like that there
better be bars on it
I don't think we disappointed
I think reason went crazy on the ship
um but yeah you reply and say next album
I got something for you no no because I
wouldn't play myself in that regard I
just don't think that's how
Drake features work
Travis he's a nice guy super nice guy he
owes me a lot of money but he's a nice
guy oh yeah don't you guys have some bet
he owes me money fifty thousand dollars
he'll never pay it because I don't
strike Drake as the guy to remember our
conversations me him Freddie Gibbs and
this guy at a bar
well he has a he has steak now he can't
give you like a voucher for 50 Grand
[__] sweet so you could bet your own
if I could lose it yeah he's got to go
to Turks Doc Rivers [__] ass cause I'm
sure he'll my luck he'll be the next
[__] coach and I want to kill myself
Drake isn't Low by staying in Turks I
know it's a beautiful island does he
live in Turks
it appears that way and I'm just gonna
go for tax reasons but that's just me
dude he bets like a million a day and
I'm like you can't do that and my
favorite you can't do that in New York
listen my thing with the steak thing you
have to do that in in Turk so listen
especially for sure for sure my thing
with steak is why is everyone on stake
that I see betting like astronomical
like the milk boys and Drake and I'm
like are they giving them this [__]
money
um I mean it could work in
a strip club type of way
because a lot of times like if you know
rappers will be booked for a strip club
and they will give them a certain amount
to give them once here but you have to
throw these like it'll go back to the
club go back to the club it's for Optics
so I could definitely see a world where
stake would give popular people a crazy
credit where you're not gonna win
anything you're not going to pull this
out but you could bet you could bet it
all lose you'll be fine yeah but if you
win you're not gonna get the money I
could see that that's good PR especially
with with the betting world now that's
the new face Jay-Z's trying to put
Caesars in Times Square what's your
favorite Drake album uh Nothing Was the
Same mine too yeah I'll probably say
that you think Drake has a classic I
would say nothing was the same as a
classic album do you think it's like a
like a good kid Mad City doggy style get
rich or die trying classic or you think
it's like a classic to you
because to me it's a classic but I would
say I would say take care would be that
classic if you were gonna talk good kid
Mad City it's about me personally me
personally I agree and I I think take
takes a class take care is a classic
album that deserves to be put in those
good kid get rich of course absolutely
it defined a time a sound it is what it
checks every box of a classic okay you
could maybe argue it's not a rap album
but it's a classic album it's a great
album and they had to stop putting
the weekend did that whole why why did
why did we all say that do wait wait
that theory that the weekend did take
care you know when they try to [__] on
Drake and they put for each person like
Quentin did this one and we like weekend
did vocals on the outro I love the
weekend meanwhile he we say he wrote the
whole out
yo you're an r b guy right so like I
think about like the dark ages of r b
that produced guys like Frank Ocean and
The Weeknd because we had this like
weird era of r b where like Neo was
doing fist pump like [__] anthems
with Pitbull and [__] Chris Brown and
Usher was saying oh my god well I am
just doing all this just terrible pop
records that were all over the [__]
radio
Trey Songz didn't budge I don't remember
a Trey Songz EDM song
there might be one but Trey at that time
was doing like actually really dope r b
mixtapes for sure he was keeping
um but I feel like out of that we did
get like the Frank Ocean and the weekend
[__] at that same time it was like House
of balloons some the summer of 2011 we
got Nostalgia Ultra we got House of
balloons and we got cocaine 80s
that's that changed and then shortly
after that Miguel had some dope I mean
Miguel's album was crazy at that time oh
kaleidoscope dreams incredible
um but that was more like Channel orange
time I think what was that
um are you in the first album all I
wanted you was though we had uh and then
I'm saying more so like what kind of
Define the way we're talking about the
blog era when it came to r b it was
Frank cocaine 80s the weekend and then
Janae was putting out her mixtapes at
that time and that I mean to me is the
genre of what this Moody dark
to somebody Whispering r b is which I I
know a lot of r b people [__] on this
new sound of r b i don't I think r b is
an amazing place and if you look there's
people that can really sing there's
people that can make really good music
there's people that can make dark Moody
whispery [__] that I like too like it
doesn't have to be defined just by the
vocalists I think we need to take care
of our vocalists
they are the unicorns and we need them
all the time but that doesn't mean we
have to [__] on everyone that can make
great records when they're Whispering I
was gonna say there's like this huge
obviously with what happened at
Coachella a lot of people were down on
Frank Ocean rightfully you know I get it
yeah for sure he [__] did a
half-assed I'm so GL I was my son's a
huge Frank Ocean fan I'm so glad I was
about to do the whole weekend I'm so
glad my tickets did not come through
because I was like you see you're
[__] this is your savior on stage
with a [__] DJ doing a random set for
30 minutes in the middle Mr King what is
this is your [__] King right here but
I still love frank but I feel like Do
You Feel Like We over like like we hold
him in a higher regard than we should
based on like the amount of music that's
actually out what also tells you of
course how good that music was I mean
he's one of the few artists in this era
that did the Mystique thing so well that
we don't know his asterisks like we have
we know all of Chris Brown's Asterix we
do all but
you have to at least Chris Brown has
given us himself whether music
personally for everything for good or
bad he's constantly put music out he's
constantly performing he's constantly
trying new things like that's great
but Frank
hasn't done that and which is fine I put
out like a fifteen thousand dollar [__]
ring
okay well I mean he did entrepreneur he
put out a piece of Dick jewelry
entrepreneur was interesting this year
um but I have a weird weird thoughts on
that too because I think we still need
those few mysterious artists like I
still like that because I grew up in
that era where it was like you didn't
know the artist and it gave you an album
and they disappeared for three years and
they came back like that's ill if you
can do that now and Frank has a master
class in that regard but it makes
moments like Coachella super magnified
if it's not good and you deserve all the
critique you get from it because you
only pop up every now and then so when
you pop up you have to make it your best
like we waited forever from Channel
orange to blonde he delivered on blonde
he kept that mystique and that Legend
going so when you're about to do
Coachella we assume if you're gonna do
Coachella you've been rehearsing for a
year you don't pop out unless it's gonna
be something yeah you would expect like
this is gonna be insane like and I
assume that there'd be music with it
like if you're gonna pop out and do
something drop a sign I don't think
Frank is is low on money I don't I mean
I don't know his habits I think the
cockering probably well I don't know did
he partner with Bluetooth I don't know
maybe promo code blue like three months
Supply it's just when you when you
disappear and have that luxury of
Disappearing and having so many so much
anticipation when you just tweet hey
right you have to deliver when it's time
to and he did not deliver so nah he
deserves the critique he's gotten
he's a legend in my opinion when it
comes to music he's one of my favorite
do you like but I mean I love Channel
orange blonde was one of those ones that
had to grow on me it grew on me I I
didn't like blonde when it first came
out almost like season two of The Wire
you know
sure that's a all right I'm not mad at
that comparison you know you watch
season two of The Wire look at all these
[__] white dudes at the [__] Pier
you know like oh no I love season two of
The Wire now like
um blonde initially I didn't hate but I
wasn't a huge fan of it as the years
went it's one of the best written albums
I think what I got to my like late 20s
around like 29
almost probably going to 30 I was like
this is this is the definition of
someone transitioning from their 20s to
their 30s right like the writing on that
album is [__] incredible it's a rap
album
like almost down to what sizza did with
SOS of just like how much her pen is all
over that crazy the way Solange they
would see it at the table where it's
just like
this isn't just r b there's so much
[__] words and content in this right
it's not just Melody driven it's not
drum driven it this is a pen blonde is
that to me it's one of the best written
albums I've ever heard but it took me
years to get there yeah I feel like
because you're just you just expect
something different there's not a wasted
syllable on blonde and it took me a
while to to realize that
um coming off Channel orange give me a
snare like what the [__] right right and
he gave us Knights oh no no Knights did
come out with it but that was the one
that they pushed
and that was the first one we heard so I
assume the rest of the album would be
like nights and I was like I have not
heard a [__] kick yet right but it's
it's a classic
um you've been putting out visualizers
for the album uh what for you because I
saw one of them that was uh inspired uh
what was the Robin Williams movie
one hour photo or he's a crazy [__]
it's an underrated movie it's it's one
of my favorite Robin William films ever
rest in peace to the God man yeah you
ever see him uh Robin Williams live on
Broadway the stand-up no I haven't It's
[__] amazing
um but all his material huh all this is
my cereal I I don't know I don't see I
don't know the the nuances of like if he
had people writing his jokes or not but
I'm a Robin Williams movie fan I I can't
say I've ever Deep dive into his Patch
Adams was fire Fair yeah [__] tear
tracker man yeah
um but what like I even like Jack Jack
was solid
Jack was good not as wait wait I he
might have started the pronoun wave
somehow what was the uh
the one with [__]
God damn it
never mind we're not even gonna go down
that road Jumanji no no no no no no no
Jack made me think of I am Sam for some
reason
no that's Sean Penn I know I know that's
why never mind
um but no I wasn't asking when it comes
to your visuals like obviously you're
not do are you you're not doing the like
I guess normal music video route you're
doing more visualizers you do it it
feels like they're more like art pieces
well again initially back to me saying I
never really wanted to be too
forward-facing with it
the initial idea with the visualizers
were going to be narrative based with
actors
maybe I would be an Easter egg like I'd
be the person working at the deli right
and the artist would also be just bigger
Easter eggs but it would be very much
narrative driven and just like with this
album as as far as scheduling dates and
how difficult that became
I was like all right I might have to get
out of my comfort zone and just do a
proper visualizer because I can't get
everyone on the same page like even I'm
sure that's the hardest part if I do it
out like this different people's
schedules getting people in person at
the same time like and not even making
the album is way easier than
every artist's release schedule because
everyone's pitching to the same playlist
everyone needs four or five weeks if
their label is I have an incredible
masego record but it just doesn't work
with timing and that's I consider masego
a friend and we would put it out if it
made sense for his career too he's got a
record out we can't put another one
because it can be primary like right
it'll push push that was the most
difficult yeah thing when it came to
putting this out but with visuals as
well so I'll just try to run through
[__] I love growing up and one hour
photo was one of those
those things that I felt
was something we could recreate and
there I mean there's metaphors within
that entire thing
which I didn't even really discuss with
I did with Raven who's one of my best
friends
um Ravi B who directed it I didn't
really discuss with her my idea of what
the metaphor of that entire thing is and
it's almost down to a Reddit thing
one hour photo is about a guy that is
obsessed with a family just develops
photos and he feels like he's a part of
that fan right and he gets so obsessed
over it that he damn near wants to kill
the husband when he makes a mistake of
keeping that family going so while I
played Robin Williams in that
that visualizer the fans are Robin
Williams they are
that was more Reddit guys that was more
so down from from Lipstick Alley down
like and you guys have a Rory and mall
like suburbs for sure okay I'm in there
too I talk it's pretty it's pretty
pretty gnarly I mean there's not like no
temperature toxic definitely not no
jumper toxic it's a mixed bag but yeah
that visualizer was was mostly I saw all
the theories of like it had to do with
my past relationship and she moved on no
that was about y'all and that's why I
thought it was so funny that the
theories that they came up were just so
off and were so much about me and my
personal life it proved my [__] point
that this visualizer you guys think you
guys know that was y'all in the glasses
walking around with my dog it's like so
funny you guys have felt you guys are a
part of my private life so right that's
what that visualizer represents that is
funny because I never spoke about that
this is the first time you guys do have
some crazy fans that's why I always like
tell like I'm always like you know I do
interviews and I want to start doing
like more just like non-interview
content but I also don't want people to
care about me that much I like
consciously like I'm very conscious
about like I don't want people to really
give a [__] that much about me but we
can also be honest and I know most
people won't admit this we also need
them to
people talk a lot of [__] about my
personal life and it is what it is
if they stop
what does that say
yeah I mean that's fair it's part of the
the game part of it it's part of the gig
I can just move accordingly and do
visualizers like enough like right
that's why I feel better about [__] like
there was like times where me and Adam
are like Adam was talking about bringing
me to no jumper to do like a weekly show
with him and I was like yeah I don't
want people to care that much bro like I
don't I don't need that [__]
I don't need those guys yeah like things
are going pretty well right now I mean
obviously I'm trying to scale I'm trying
to do different [__] but I'm like man
those [__] those guys are [__]
they're into your [__] like posting your
girl and [__] and I'm like I couldn't do
it I mean that's even with with the kid
thing I mean I I put the IG clip out
it's funny calling it The Kid thing you
know fatherhood yeah
um
that was a big thing I was I had to
figure out after like it
set in and I started to get in the
Rhythm
of being a father was all right I have a
podcast and I already see people on
Reddit and all these other shits talking
about it like because I wasn't hot I was
like walking around with my kid if you
saw me you saw my child yeah yeah like
but people are already talking about it
and every everyone around me knew even
yeah it wasn't anything hidden per se
but in the podcast World it wasn't
something I was talking about
yeah you guys are so obsessed with
personal [__] [__] it when I put an
album out I'm eventually going to talk
about my kid what a perfect time as you
should the amount of people that were
like this piece of [__] is using his
kids
y'all are the reason why
you guys forced my hand
and I would have talked about it
probably earlier but no let's [__] it
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at Blue chew
baby that's right it's getting hot
outside you know what that means fellas
you about to go get that dick wet you
know what I'm saying it might as well be
really hard it might as well be as hard
as it could possibly be and with
Bluetooth you will achieve such hardness
all right it's seriously amazing uh and
the best part about Bluetooth is you can
find out if it works don't just take my
word for it they're going to give you a
month's supply for free go to
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get a month supply for free
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg now
it's the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis minus the awkward
doctor appointment you do not have to go
see some old dude and tell them about
your erectile dysfunction issues in
person because that's a [__] awkward
conversation bruh all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com right now use the
promo code bootleg they're going to get
you hooked up with a month of supply for
free you just just got to pay five
dollars in shipping no awkward doctor's
appointments same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis plus they got the
Bluetooth mint it's a chewable it's
great tastes like mint it's also the
same active ingredient as Levitra so
summertime's coming fellas you don't
want to underperform make sure your dick
is rocked up baby all right go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
hey man it works what do you want from
me it [__] works everyone should have
a little Bluetooth in case of an
emergency
you might have an emergency you need to
pop a Bluetooth to it it's a chewable
you know what I mean anyway also got a
shout out to our family at Odd Socks
don't forget go to oddstocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg save 20 off man they
got the underwear that they just dropped
uh last year that's amazing so not only
do you get the most comfortable socks in
the world but you can also get the most
comfortable withdrawals in the world all
the crazy licenses they gotta have baked
socks they just announced their Hasbro
collection which is crazy because that
means you're going to get Monopoly socks
Transformer socks Power Ranger socks so
much [__] going with Odd Socks plus they
got The Odd Socks Basics my favorite
this is why I wear every day I wear the
basics because they're the most
comfortable socks I've ever put on my
[__] feet so experience the most
comfortable socks in the world with me
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off shout out to Odd Socks let's
get back to the interview all right look
man uh
shout out [__] we've just had a little
off-camera conversation yes great
commercial break there right commercial
we just came out of a Bluetooth
commercial yes well we weren't talking
about that ah dude let me ask you this
you got because I've been going through
this a little bit more recently
um
where I've had like fan bases like come
at me crazy I've had like uh the little
cam fans thousands of Tweets in like 24
hours just on my [__] head yeah
um and then recently the Dirk fans which
is crazy uh okay what do you say about
Dirk nothing crazy me and uh the kids
from uh
uh what's it what's what's it gen Rivera
and uh Kyle Rich you would know drill
guy over there Benner the 41 kids from
Brooklyn
Jen Carter Jen Carter and Kyle Rich who
are these drill kids from Brooklyn that
well I support them they're from New
York super nice guys but I'm just and
Lady um but no we were talking about who
is bigger little baby or little Dirk and
they were like emphatically like man
Dirk and I was like well Dirk doesn't
have any hit records
oh yes I did say that you I did see this
clue uh I thought it was a fair point
that you made yeah and I was like top
tens he doesn't have any like he just
doesn't have a top no now he does
by the way do we know that officially
though yeah it's number two on the
Billboard Hot 100 okay the first time
he's ever been the like his his song and
it's a [__] smash incredible shout
out to Dirk but man the [__] fan yo
he's you would all these [__] weirdos
who swear they're OTF and they live in
their [__] mom's basement in
Scottsdale Arizona or some [__] like
it's [__] crazy yeah no they can't
get like what has been the craziest like
moment where because you guys openly
just talk about music so I'm assuming at
a certain point in time you had caught
some Strays from some of these wild fan
base oh uh barbs and it's not even close
yeah but it's not it wasn't based off of
a comment I made
um we had interviewed Nikki and I
brought up remember that I brought up a
question that I still
think is a fair question to ask somebody
I had asked Nikki at what point do you
and I'm paraphrasing it was recorded I
don't remember right but it was
something along the lines of why do you
feel like you have to respond to all
this like why do you let that type of
[__] get to you and she she had a very
fair response of if you had people
because she was she was comparing the
difference between
her fan base and mine which is a very
fair thing it's like
if you had people just continuing to
make rumors up about you you would feel
a way too and I replied I was like I
probably wouldn't
um which was foreshadowing because I
kind of did later right so barbs barbs
you may got one yeah um she said what
what would you feel if
somebody started a rumor that someone
stuck a broomstick up your ass Nicki
Minaj said this to me eye to eye on
camera
I could refresh my mentions I don't even
know what year that was I could refresh
my mentions right now and there may be a
photo of me on a Harry Potter broom and
a Barb saying how's that broom up your
ass it is not stopped for seven years
wow yeah no the barbs are resentless and
I [__] with Nikki I always have but they
don't that's the crazy thing about the
bars though they won't look for who's
supporting they'll find one off comment
and go crazy so I said something about
um
and I didn't care about them I said
something and mind you maybe I I I I was
a victim of the assumption that little
Kim did not or had a lot of help from
biggie writing hardcore
I think that's fair to say right so I
had said something to that
effect when me and Nick Cannon were
discussing the female goats because he
said Lauren and then he put Kim above
Nikki and I was like well could you do
that if Kim
big your own [__] you know like I don't
know so um I'll go on a limb and this
isn't just try to make up for the
broomstick [__] to get the bars off my
ass if Kim wrote all her [__] I would
still put Nikki above Kim I don't think
they're Fair comparisons in the amount
of time Nikki has been in the game and
how consistent she's the greatest of all
time I agree with you I think Nikki is
the greatest female rapper of all and so
dude and I think you could make a case
that Nikki could be in a list of the
greatest yeah like top 15 yeah yeah I
think I would be fine with that case but
no but Jesus I didn't know little Kim
had these [__] goons out here on the
internet bruh well you know I will say
uh I don't know if you read Prodigy's
book I did not that's uh another classic
um listen to the audiobook because it's
cooler to hear P tell those stories is
that the one where he talked about Nori
shooting him yeah okay for sure
um and amongst a lot of other things but
he said that he watched Kim write that
quiet storm verse and that made me look
at Kim a little different one of the
best verses ever that she wrote things
that I watched her write that entire
thing so yes of course biggie did help I
know clue had leaked references of
Biggie rapping to ask him that's
happening hip-hop I don't want to take
anything away from Kim in that regard
but I still would say Nikki just is the
is the best she's been out she put out
way more like what do you I don't know
if they'll be a kid without Nikki you
could have that argument but I think
that's a weird argument to have let's
deal with what's out because there
wouldn't be a there wouldn't be a Jay-Z
without you know I don't like that what
you're about to say but I don't like
that convo either but I'm saying like it
doesn't matter like that doesn't matter
like at the end of the day it's like
it's like I don't factor that I like to
look at like lyrical ability catalogs
songs like like how good is the music
like and I love Kim's music like I love
you know Kim's Kim's a legend but yeah I
didn't know that her fans also like her
and cardi B have like the same like um
they're kind of like in the same gang
kind of so I've noticed a lot of these
bios or like names would be like party
game queen b77 or some [__] and I was
like
yo I didn't know bro well I I got caught
up in the the cardigan [__] by proxy
like I was supporting cardi but Maul was
suggesting she needs to put out music
you can't have album of the year and
then just wait this long like you had
the best she can rookie year of any
rapper ever yeah and you haven't put any
music out like what the [__] singles
very successful ones and then cardi went
on live [__] on Maul said Damaris was
the greatest human being ever who's on
our show as well and I somehow just got
tied in with moles
like this again I just had this talk
about cardi I can't have beef with Nikki
and cardi don't pick one size I just had
to talk with somebody last night about
cardi uh who who's at Atlantic we were
just talking like it is kind of like
we've never seen somebody come out with
like a classic debut album that is like
literally every song's a hit like I mean
I think they're all certified platinum
at this point but only streaming that's
also an unfair conversation only
streaming could allow that true and
that's not to take away because I I was
on the side that cardi put out a classic
album there's not a bad every song is a
hit it's amazing and you can't like that
would be unheard of you can't work 13
records at Radio you can't that would
never exist in the world before only
streaming since like of course she had
she's she's had you know shout out to
her she she got pregnant right before I
think the tour with Bruno Mars was gonna
happen
um but she's put out some really great
singles like up is a [__] Banger bro
like the [__] and the her verse with
glorilla at a moment and my thing is
making me I was one of the best verses
of as long as she keeps having these
incredible moments
like the album I'm sure is being worked
on but she's got a song on offs I I was
with her in offset Super Bowl uh and
offset play me his album and she has a
song on offset solo album that she's
[__] snapping on here this [__] is
crazy
oh my God and you know what the one
thing with cardi is like
I'm not sure like how much stuff she's
writing not writing getting help with
but I'll be damned man I [__] love
listening to cardi B Brad Paul like you
know like I said pause she has she'll be
delivering bro one of the best
deliveries oh my God ever how
charismatic she is on records is
incredible uh since we're just two
straight white males talking about women
hip-hop I don't know if you saw it today
Taylor Swift I spice I saw that we
talked about it on my radio show
I said does this are you ready
I'm not
um are you ready is a wild question for
that so I mean shout out to I spice I do
think that I think I might have saw you
guys had a conversation about I spice on
your Show recently right that tied into
the cardi response okay yeah yeah so I
saw you guys talking about I spice
um and I feel like she has Star Quality
definitely does um and her she could rap
good enough
yeah for sure
um she does she does caption wrap that's
super important yeah I just think that
uh for sure caption wrap is I mean
probably breaks the god of caption wrap
you know but but Drake like raps raps
and does that for sure for sure uh yeah
Drake's one of the greatest of all time
I'm always on Drake says pick my [__]
money bro
um but now I spice it's just
I don't I don't know if I've heard them
I haven't heard the record yet where I'm
like oh she's gonna be here for a while
she's here right now she's lit like I
think her getting on that Pink Panther's
record is supposed to break because
that's like I think at a certain point
in time is the number one song in the
world but to me that showed that she may
be around because Pink Panther's being
one of the up and coming younger artists
I love that they got together this
Taylor Swift thing is that scares me
you're why you're not skipping steps per
se you're
you're just going you're chasing the
bigger look whereas the Pink Panther
[__] we know that both two emerging
artists it makes so much sense the
record is fire the videos fire like it
made perfect sense did you see Taylor
Swift
I like ice baths that's let's get her on
something and even like with Nikki that
that made sense to me too like both New
York she's a fan like that all that made
sense for sure this and this is not a
judge on Taylor Swift it could be any
huge pop star that's nowhere near the
age range of I spice I'd be like
you may be going too fast you're going a
little too fast
it's not gonna say no of course if
you're ice spice you're not gonna be
like Taylor Swift called and she wants
to use you as the cool hit part of her
next song you know and and that's where
these conversations are weird too
because when we talked about the cardi
record with Dirk and Kanye I was like
you're not gonna say no to a dirk and
Kanye
verse on this record right but what
killed that record Dirk and Kanye yeah
yeah I agree if if that record would
have been just already went crazy if it
would have just been her for two verses
it probably would have and and by the
way also shout out to the Atlantic team
they took that record number one at
rhythm in in urban but that song was
number one yeah a radio
but it wasn't the song that like
you know it was things go number one and
not work at all at Radio yes yes yeah I
think out of all the singles she's been
dropping that was the one where you were
like she put that snippet up of her
sitting on that roof in the robe with
her version she killed it but you're
right Eric and Kanye I saw that I said
oh cardi B is back then I heard the song
and I was like oh cardi went crazy and
then cardi went crazy and not to say
Dirk and Kanye were bad on it it just it
was weird it just ruined us all do you
listen to a lot of little Dirk no
I
I just not my type of [__] I wish I had
a better response in these types of
things because I respect Dirk me too I
feel like we've seen him like kind of
grow up in front of our eyes great you
know back when we talk about like
Sycamore when Sycamore was doing his
mixtapes like I love Dirk at that time
it's it's just it wasn't something for
me to begin with so I'm not hating by
any degrees it's just not my [__] yeah
I'm I'm very much in the same boat with
you I respect Dirk I got I I there's
records I really enjoy there's records I
really like hell tracks and
with hellcats and trackhawks is [__]
I play that [__] every time I DJ you
know he's he's extremely talented
deserves all the success like he is he's
one of those I [__] with him in that
regard it's just not something that I'm
gonna stop just my taste what about
little baby
baby's another one that
I prefer them on features I [__] love
little baby man no they're great I'm
just I'm a baby girl rap though of
course I'm stuck can too I'm not saying
they can't it's just not my go-to no no
dirkin rap but baby can rap
like I feel like I've heard baby like
run circles around [__] on
record so I'm just like like once in
need maybe for me and again I'm not in
that Khalid record I'm not somebody like
when he goes into the studio I'm not
someone he would think of I'm not saying
personally for sure my type of consumer
I like baby and Dirk on features like
when they just get one verse to shine I
think they do it better than any new
rappers out for like they make the
record theirs I mean dude it's a talent
but the whole Channel record the push
heisty record is like you've only play
you play the you playing it for the Dirk
first yeah because that's the part
people sing along too and Dirk is able
to rap and do like certain tricks and
stuff on songs by tricks I mean like
parts that everyone's gonna sing along
to like uh don't play a little boy in
the club we don't listen like that that
no one knows the talent that that one
line takes [__] the content of just the
melody like to stop everyone and what
we're gonna sing along to Dirk has that
and he can rap and he can make music I'm
just not running I just maybe it's my
age maybe it's right my region I I just
not my [__] did you have any time to see
uh his sit down with academic [__] no I
haven't I I saw the one clip of have you
seen the clips yeah
what was the clip about the Gunner thing
I think that was the only thing I saw
you and academics still uh you guys have
a pretty uh you guys have a conflict I
wouldn't say so well I think he he
doesn't like you much what but you know
what but it's crazy that he doesn't like
you much and you guys have kind of had
this back and forth for years ever since
everyday struggle was on right
I don't know if it's been a back and
forth I've certainly said things what
before but not anything that but I also
when you were discussing the list you
said nice things
he doesn't deserve to be on that [__]
yeah and that's where the internet
will will they'll see this clip and be
like w freck no no I'm an objective
human being like I know there's nuanced
objectiveness to every situation yeah
and we're also on the internet so like
yes if we're talking about a list I
believe academics should be on that if
something is in person
I'm not going to talk about the list
right I'm gonna ask you like in terms of
these are drastically different things I
can give people their credit where it's
due for sure I was gonna say in terms of
like we kind of started this combo
talking about hip-hop media for a sec
but like how do you kind of see and I'm
happy about those
this is not going to come across I know
people are going to think this is a
sarcastic shot I'm very happy that um he
was not harmed in that home invasion
because that that could have went really
bad so I I'm this is a real thing he
said horrible lies and weird [__] about
me I'm very happy he was not harming
that that home invasion that could have
got really bad when's the home invasion
uh from my understanding recently two
people who tried to break into it yeah
very recently and they were arrested he
could I don't know if he was making that
up or not but wait didn't you send him
like a Christmas card didn't you send
something to his house man like where
like people were like oh that that's
that's [__] yes okay that was so
funny though like
Elizabeth I have no issue with anybody I
think that's funny that that's a that's
a that's like a thing good good keep
keep the narrative going I think it's
[__] hilarious and I do mean this
wholeheartedly I know his fans are gonna
hate this because they want me to say
something I know my fans are gonna be
like was this some [__] [__] like the
amount of personal things that I'm so
glad with what's been going on he was
not harmed in that home invasion
because from what I read it could have
been those guys was ready so was he just
not home
I don't know the foot something about
some girls set him up if I'm him I got a
safe room at the house I think a girl
set him up but it's not my story to tell
I just saw some clips you know I stay on
Reddit so I do see what other people
type I can't say that they are the best
source but yeah I saw that something
happened with the girl set him up and
two people were arrested and they had
guns and they were Jesus Christ somebody
was unlocking the door at his house and
I
his girlfriend and listen I don't wanna
I may disagree with a lot of [__]
things that that kid
stands for says whatever I'm so happy he
wasn't harmed because this [__] this
[__] is getting insane with home
invasions and I want to see anybody just
people losing their life in general yeah
that kid uh I think it was in Texas that
kid who like posted the picture and
standing in the guy's blood and then
that same day got killed did you see
that no
and even not what he was saying I think
his I think act's Mom was in there like
that that [__] is like
that's that [__] is [__] up bro so
that's [__] out yeah that's just not
funny it's just not cool like but I feel
for bro yeah are you like uh you some
would say he may deserve it but I don't
think someone deserves that like that's
my thing with AK is like I think when he
first came onto the scene because I was
not hip to his YouTube [__] at all prior
I had no idea who he was prior to
Everyday struggle so
when the everyday struggle started to
pop I kind of got a kick out of this
like internet dude who genuinely came
off like a fan who was like happy to be
there in a lot of these conversations he
was having because Joe Budden would be
there yeah and that's why I like that
conversation with the Migos the BET was
so funny because he just was so green
and like happy to be talking to the
Migos and I think there was a moment
where he just became like big ack and it
was like
you know what I mean like his Persona of
like being like this [__] this guy
you know and I'm like sometimes I like
and I respect dudes like he's a hustler
you know like I ain't mad at him like
but I also think a certain point in
times will act is like
you you kind of don't seem like the
greatest dude you know like uh but I
don't I don't know him personally yeah
neither do I to be fair yeah as much as
there's been a an insane narrative that
anything in my life has been affected by
him which is like absolutely
egregiously false and hilarious I I
don't yeah it's more power to him wasn't
it like keep going bro have a blast like
there's nothing has been affected in my
life how do you see like uh the
evolution of like the space that we're
all in right like you said we were
talking earlier what is hip-hop media
nowadays like there's the twitch guys
there's the kai sonats and then who's
now in Rumble I think
um but it just feels like it's like
forever an evolving
thing like how do you feel about where
it's going and and where it's at I mean
that's kind of
I want to ask you that question at the
beginning of the interview where hip-hop
media is that's why that list
was so interesting to me outside of what
everyone else thought as far as the
messiness
where is hip-hop media going to go
because we see with these live streaming
sites even with Rumble and everything
hip-hop is not going to get it done
so by itself yeah it's
I fear hip-hop media will get pushed out
of this entire world I think it'll
hip-hop gossip will continue to thrive
don't get me wrong hip hop media will
lose its strength unless
somebody in that and I'm not even mad at
the people that are
interviewing these guys but it's the
audience that we probably have to blame
unfortunately yeah myself included I
click all this relationship me too
hip-hop gossip is what is what's going
to keep this [__] going I don't know
where hip-hop journalism
is really gonna lie in the next 10 years
especially with the younger kids and I'm
not being the old guy saying you young
kids don't have it their worlds are just
different and so much of that gaming
[__] and everything that is going to be
so profitable with live streams and
podcasts
I don't really see where hip-hop
journalism really Falls and I also don't
see these
hip-hop artists and the younger
generation caring to do that they don't
already
drink Champs is incredible I'm so happy
that Nori is able to talk to not only
new artists but people from his
generation because those are great
conversations for sure and those artists
also went on radio interviews press was
a part of their [__] life it's not
weird to them it's it's part of their
their being right these young kids don't
have to go do that they don't so that's
not part of their DNA which leaves the
the media people
having to find other ways to do it
whether that be gaming whether that be
other interests whether that be
comedians let's interview gang members
exactly I spent an hour on YouTube [__]
last night watching brick baby and [__]
Mack on no jumper say [__] on on
neighborhood like for two hours straight
it was the I dude it was the most
entertaining
YouTube should have watched in a long
time and I'm saying what what's going to
be more popular within hip-hop
journalism or media if a rapper does an
interview or someone does a whole gang
breakdown of The Gang That rapper came
from what's gonna get more clicks oh the
the the Gang video because we've seen it
with like swamp stories and like these
these uh which by the way watch those
are all great platforms they do real
research like dude I remember I had to
interview uh yeah where does that leave
hip where is hip-hop Journal at some
point Elliot Wilson is going to want to
retire and go live with his wife and
he's like the last guy that you're like
oh that person did a Rap Radar interview
oh and I know for us there's younger
kids out here that want to do that I
just don't know if the artists are going
to want to do that and I don't know if
Elliot gives a [__] to
do every hot up-and-coming artists
they're very selective of course not why
would yeah of course he'll do NBA young
boy it's NBA young boy you know like
you know so yeah so you you just kind of
see it evolving into like the
journalistic Integrity continuing to be
diminished but that's not a because it's
already kind of there that's not a
slight A hip-hop or the culture I mean
look
let's let's look at the number one news
outlets TMZ
CNN Fox News there's no journalism
Integrity there either so why would I
think Hip-hop would follow suit it's the
worst like America does not follow suit
on journalism that has changed that's
become a circus that's about clicks
that's about salacious [__] of course
hip-hop is going to end up the world is
that way there's not one real journalism
platform
I mean you could find
depending on your political views
certain ones but I don't know if there's
like objective journalism happening in
the world period period so to have that
everybody has their angle and everyone
has their yes you're right so hip-hop
media and then these artists don't
playlist is what I need I don't know if
I need to go I'll go do yeah I'll go to
the rap caviar podcast and on top of
that
if I got beef with the artist I'm gonna
have a salacious clip I have my own
[__] Instagram I also can set up a
microphone why do I need y'all
I remember thinking that um I was like
man I was just talking with uh one of my
friends about this the other day
I was like if you're an artist in
today's
you know landscape
a lot of these guys
an interview can only hurt you
right yes like they don't like this will
probably hurt me like nothing new
from me sitting down with
whoever it is
is going to necessarily move the needle
for me but it can hurt me yeah you know
so it's like why even do it like if it's
just the the really the only uh like the
the downside is
very much there and the upside's not
very
measurable like and I uh
I'm stealing this I think from Steve
Stout's book but
you you'll know how popular an artist is
now only based by the tickets that they
sell if you want to know how big an
artist is go go to the show so I relate
that a lot to podcasting not so much
with the live show thing
but how much views are you getting
without it guest right and that's where
the media [__] is moving you have to be
a personality so much that
you will move the needle weakly
by yourself or with your co-host
whatever and those are moments when you
have an artist to have a real interview
and I think journalism can happen in
that regard I think you know Maul and I
haven't had like the crazy salacious
[__] but the interviews we have done
whether it be Russ or DJ Drama like I
think did you guys have belly on we did
uh we cook lamb chops with Billy okay I
mean we had a nice conversation but I
wouldn't say it was an interview per se
no but you guys I do feel like you're
right like when I see you guys do an
interview I'm like oh [__] like I know
you guys really [__] with the artist
yeah and even if we don't it's
kind of has to be a reason outside of
just to talk like oh they're doing the
podcast run and that's where I see the
value with hip-hop media whether you're
the media person or the artist what is
actually going to make sense and move
the needle for both of you and I don't
know where that's going to happen in
hip-hop journalism unless all the
hip-hop media personalities can keep an
audience without an artist that gives an
artist an incentive to go on there if
I'm an artist and you can't do that
I'm bringing my audience to you I'll
just set up a [__] microphone and go
on IG live that's what's like I think
for me I've been like okay well one I'm
syndicated on the radio all over the
country every [__] but you actually
do and why I said you belong on that
list is you actually do the journalism
interviews actually anytime as a I just
had a young nudie interview yesterday
where we just got high the whole time
and talked about [__] Pinky you know
the porn chick from back in the day you
know but that separated you in this
space I feel like because you have real
interviews and you're not you're way
more consistent than Elliot because
Elliot works on a different time and
like I like I'll just like if I like
somebody I'm like I want to talk like I
know it's not gonna do numbers but I
want to interview this person you know
like and that's valuable I just don't
know how long it's gonna I want to
interview big X the plug so bad if you
listen to this guy no he's from Dallas
he's so [__] hard bro DM and his guy
all the [__] time like bro when the
[__] y'all coming to L.A big X the plug
he's on United Masters so he's a Steve
Style guy but he's hard bro
he's got a song called Texas but he's
got a big a song called Big stepper he's
got bruh
he's yeah
but see to me that's kind of how I got
involved in this whole [__] was like I
was just a hip-hop head and I started
doing radio because I couldn't rap or
make beats or did you try to rap I wrote
raps I never tried like I never wouldn't
trust you if you didn't try no I tried
okay yeah I don't trust it I didn't say
I tried I wrote stuff like I'd be in
school writing rats yeah I never like
performed or recorded a verse or
anything I just have a weird thing I
don't trust anyone that didn't at least
try no I wrote for sure I would just
like write hell of scribbles and [__] um
but you know for me it's almost like you
said it's like
not only am I doing the the YouTube and
and that but I'm also on the radio so
I'm like if I play someone's song once
it's 25 spins yeah and I'm on Monday
through Friday so it's like I'm BR like
I kind of have that Advantage going for
me but I definitely like you know I
moved into this new new compound so
we're gonna start rolling out like just
different
non-interview types of content because
like you said how long is that Gonna
Last yeah you know what I mean it's like
it's it's really like but again at least
you have the the luxury of having a
staple in the podcast culture that we
know we're gonna get a real interview
from someone where there is a lot of
guest based pods that just it's [__]
and they rely on a guest every single
time you and Elliot at least we know
like yeah this will be a a form
interview I mean I'm not sure this one
was but I'm not a rapper oh
all my fault but yeah um
you know like even when the Gib [__] was
happening like yeah when he popped up
with you I'm not sure which Gibbs when
I'm in the timeline here yeah which I
was like at least I I know this is gonna
be a real interview gonna be a real
conversation because Kev gets respect
from every rapper I know they'll have a
real conversation it'll go somewhere
Kevin's gonna ask real questions that's
so lost in the guest based podcast world
yeah and that's why I don't think it's
gonna yeah the red thing was like for
like you are an anomaly well Fred's one
of my best friends so you know for me it
when he beefs with the world it
complicates my relationship with the
world
God bless him love Freddie but I'm the
guy who gets the call like yo what's
[__] s dot just called me three days
ago and was like what is this Freddie
Gibbs I'm seeing on Twitter and I'm like
yeah
I don't want to get into it man I'm too
close to the situation gotta be the name
of this album right I I love the fact
that he leaned into it because he's but
he's the best at the internet he's the
best I knew he would do that he had to
lean into it man and like you know yeah
but somebody said that he was spreading
his stink star and he replied with yo
you got big titties
[Applause]
like what that's the only way you could
reply to that great great response it's
a perfect Twitter response she said
something hilarious and so do you yeah
and my other thing too is I try not to
you know I try not to dive into like the
low-hanging fruit like beef [__] like or
like
you know I just some [__] I'm like I'd
rather I would just rather not
intentionally add to certain [__] now I
might end up adding to certain [__] but
it ain't you know some some of these
platforms and like I watch them you know
like I I got love for lad and all those
guys I watched Vlad [__] all the time
but it's just like I don't know for me
it's like at the moment it's working but
you're right it's like the guest based
[__] is like at what a certain point in
time like
it's definitely gotta evolve into
something else and you guys have done
such a great job of
doing that because people are there for
you guys and if you guys haven't have a
guest
[__] sweet it's gonna be a great
interview because you guys do great
great conversations
um if you had Vlad on what would be the
first question you would ask them
uh
[__] man I don't know I've asked Vlad to
come on the podcast because he'll text
me sometimes or call me sometimes
and he said I didn't have enough viewers
for him
he said it wasn't popping so I think I
think I got the text here but I mean but
I just honesty I guess I don't know I
mean and I I respect hey hey also I
wasn't I didn't take that [__]
personally I wouldn't have taken that
person I was like hey bro I get it yeah
all good like hopefully one day you know
like he had hit me for a contact on
cannabis
oh you know what it was he called me
because he was like I didn't want to
send this over a text he was like but
you know I'm looking at your numbers I'm
like you know and I'm like dude you're
[__] Rich yeah so for you to like
take time away from your family take
time away from your business I get it
bro all good I didn't take it flat is
Rich he's never told us that he tells us
that a lot I had no idea I mean have you
seen the way he dresses no he's not on
camera well no sometimes when he is it's
like [__] Louie ever he you know how
they say you can either wear the
designer or let the designer wear you I
would say the designers wearing Vlad he
walks into sacks and just give me the
mannequin give me the whole [__] give me
the glasses give me the [__] shorts
give me the shoes give me the socks yes
you know it's uh shots of Life by the
way rap phenomenon was it the first one
it was a rap phenomenon too that he was
the the Tupac one Tupac one Tupac went
great was that the one Green Lantern I
believe so yeah him and him and Green
Lantern Green Lantern's a goat huh
absolutely yeah as green should do more
podcasting I feel like me and him were
just together in Vegas and uh he has a
lot of stories he probably just can't
tell that's that's what it is because
green green lab had great conversations
where I'm like this would be the
greatest he's got tons of those and
I just man
I just want to know like you know the
Eminem [__] what happened with this I
mean we know what happened with the
shady [__] with like the Jadakiss G Unit
[__] or whatever yeah but
this guy was Jay-Z's DJ Eminem's DJ and
he's Nazis DJs no way it's a goat he
doesn't have some wild but but if you
know Green which you know him there
there's just I don't think there's a
chance in hell he'll ever like really
dive into a lot of that [__] he told me
though a couple weeks ago on 420 because
we were doing Jardine in Vegas together
and he was like
I'm gonna do your podcast when I have
something to promote
I did say that similar yes yeah you told
me the same way
he has nothing to promote you know he
put out that Big Pun Jada song but green
is kind of like uh speaking of Vlad I've
seen vlad's like moved into the mafia
part of YouTube which I I get I respect
it you have to grow the page but you
know picking the people that already
have huge numbers in the mafia space and
telling the same stories that were out
already but I get it Vlad is a different
audience green is like that but music
industry wise when I look at the mob
[__] I'm like if this guy's telling the
story
obviously either ratted or he's lying
because he wouldn't be able to sell this
he wouldn't be Irene is like that for me
with hip-hop he can't get on a mic and
talk about it he wouldn't be someone you
could interview because you even see
people in hip-hop that go on these like
the behind the scenes guys that tell
these crazy stories I'm like
I have to be lying because
the people that tell this story aren't
going to tell it I feel like Vlad has
one of those guys on the show every two
weeks oh it's entertaining we're like yo
there's just this random like bodyguard
and he's just saying like I know who
killed Tupac I mean I was under the
[__] I was under the Mercedes I had a
GoPro at the time before they came out
and then vlado like he interviewed he
interviewed someone that pulled up on a
bicycle to the Tupac scene I was like
are you kidding I believe it was the
first responder he just happened to be
on a Schwinn are you are you serious I
swear to God
listen I have a lot I have a lot of
disagreements with Vlad uh that's great
though him and I I guess don't get along
I don't know I have a lot of issues with
people I've never met or spoken to right
um
but uh yeah when there's positive things
to watch Vlad related I watch yeah I
just watched uh him and Charlemagne and
I watched uh him in uh who was he look
at the growth of charlemen I watched a
few of those Clues too yeah Charlie
man's a grown ass man now I love it it's
great oh it's like finding out Santa
isn't real [__] hey I'm nervous
the album is out yes I thought it'd be
different May 27th 6th I can't remember
anything what do you know the artwork
because it's real art um all the artwork
was by a gentleman by the name of Ezra
Cohen um for the people that have
watched our podcast visually when it was
at my house now we're in a new studio
but the artwork behind us that you can
kind of see because it's so big Ezra did
he did all the singles the album like
he's one of the most talented painters
uh I think out period and him even doing
the music thing
was cool because he's very much in the
art world like he's Gallery Lower East
Side Right Studio Hell's Kitchen like
he's not in our world so the fact that
he was so open to do this stuff was
amazing you have to pay him
of course um yeah I mean I I don't know
if he's like yo man everyone can speak
to my business on this album there's a
way to do good business no matter what I
hate when people would say industry
standards no there's a way that's a
facade there's a way to do good business
um even if Ezra seti do it for free I
wouldn't do that yeah take care of him
of course he he worked and worked really
well in this project so
um how many songs is it 13 13 records
tons of features dope production on the
album compilation I mean
had to be features I mean it is
accomplished you're not rapping you're
not seeing it I might on the second one
who knows
you know what's funny when I would
always hear you drop these nuggets about
you were working on an album yeah I was
like oh [__] I didn't know Rory wrapped
I'm like I rap on the show pretty often
but people don't but I was like I just
was like I just assumed you were like
gonna rap because it was like this like
secret project that you had yeah you
know working on I'm like oh [__] we're
always making music I knew you were
working with uh emotional oranges yeah
because you manage them shots I've known
as odd for
I played he was supposed to pull up but
I had a doctor's appointment yeah so I
played his song spider webs on the radio
in Las Vegas in 2010 on my underground
hip-hop show yeah very talented super
talented and help me I mean ep the
project with me Azad that's that's my
partner that's my guy great guy the best
so he he was a instrumental with no pun
intended part of this entire process so
it was it was great to have his uh help
me with this and just having emotional
orange is part of it just our internal
production crew like
this this really wasn't like send out
records like
like send beats like this was start
start from scratch some you know 30
second ideas Maybe started but
yeah this was very much a creating an
album because you know a lot of times
you'd be like yo this guy probably sent
beats out got put together some
uncohesive record oh for sure just give
me a 16 and I'll figure the rest out
yeah build around that you know like and
even like the the few times that artists
weren't in there they'll they'll send
just their verse over maybe just keys or
maybe just a drum loop I sent right and
then we go in in Frankenstein the entire
thing like it was wrong still Shelley or
is he back to drum he was drum Shelly
and now he's back to drum yeah okay is
he good he's good drama's great yeah
drama one of the most talented people
I've ever he once fell asleep during an
interview on camera with me what year
was it though because a thousand
hmm 16. okay drama's sober now
yes drama is sober now drama is doing
amazing
um again one of the most talented people
I ever worked one of the fastest workers
I'm a slow worker when it comes to music
like it's gonna take me some time and I
cooked up I want you but you'll never
know it's on my album and phone can die
which is on his in one weekend and each
session was like an hour and a half
charms like it was [__] crazy how
fast we worked together and that may be
chemistry but also drama is just an
alien in that regard and yeah one of the
most talented people uh anything on the
way uh that you could speak on any uh
podcast stuff you guys are working on
anything live show how do you guys do
the live show thing obviously the merch
is booming yeah so uh we actually have
more more March coming what was the bare
minimum boys t-shirt you can go by yeah
it's off the market now it's just for a
day you could buy it
um but we have our actual merch which
you know we pride ourselves on having
the best merch in the podcast space like
it's it's not tour T-Shirts patreon that
you drive once and are gone but yes
patreon
um we're in our new studio now we have a
I mean by the time you're hearing this
we have more sketches out I think
tomorrow Monday
two weeks we with this new studio space
and office space you know we're back to
getting in the actual Rhythm so would
you do another podcast because you know
there's a lot of people especially in
the comedic world
that they do like multiple podcasts like
you got like uh you know Tom sigour he
doesn't know his wife yeah he doesn't
want Bert Chrysler you know like
um I haven't pitched it to him but
Terrell Grace who has one of my favorite
YouTube platforms where he has R B
singers come on and they do like a uh
like a word game where he'll say a word
and they have to sing a song that has
that word in it like with a singer right
one of my favorite platforms by far and
just like one of the coolest guys I
think on YouTube I would love to do some
type of r b thing with him that'd be
dope but he may be too big for me now I
don't know well because there's like
only I think the r b money podcast and
then what you guys and what Joe I feel
like you and you guys and Joe's and we
weren't even like we touched upon r b we
weren't an RnB let's talk about it yeah
so I think that space definitely has a
voice of fill and this album can start
that but again you know I needed a year
to get this [__] off the ground with a
new one ghost ghosts run it up stream it
yes um I thought it'd be different
thought it'd be different on all
platforms buy it vinyl will be out
probably next year because I should take
yeah
[__] takes [__] forever very long
time um but designing the artwork for
that now they have the Masters and we
found a company that I think can turn it
over in less than a year so there it is
man well I appreciate you pulling up I
appreciate you having me finally made it
happen you might have something to
promote been wanting to do this for
quite some time but you know this made
more sense appreciate you man appreciate
you boom fire
hey we gotta wrap up an interview
brought to you by hardean Las Vegas
appreciate y'all watching hey don't
forget when you go to Vegas you got to
go to Hardee man it's the craziest
dispensary you'll ever walk into it
smells like [__] heaven in there all
right get in that Uber when you hit Sin
City tell them take me to hardine
they're gonna take you you're gonna get
a wild selection of the just top top of
the line cannabis the best selection
you'll go uh be able to see in the US
Plus on top of that they got the crazy
gear they got the clothes they got the
bikinis they got a wonderful selection
of Bud tenders that are very good at
their job man they'll take care of you
tell them that bootleg have sent you the
bud tenders are Harding don't know what
that means they're gonna get you hooked
up right all right go follow them online
Harding underscore Las Vegas or just go
check out their website too man
hardinglasvegas.com and when you're in
Vegas pull up to Jardine or you're
playing yourself for real